-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
We're about to play a game
of "Catch Phrase,"
but Tariq and I need partners.
Tariq, we found
a great one for you.
You can see her on
the Emmy-winning drama series
"Westworld," which returns for
its fourth season on Sunday,
June 26th on HBO and HBO max.
Please welcome Evan Rachel Wood!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you kidding me?
Come on.
-Nice to see you.
-Good to meet you.
Always the best to see you,
buddy.
Welcome.
-[ Chuckles ]
-My partner's new album,
"Superache,"
is out later tonight.
Give it up for Conan Gray,
everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You feeling good?
-Feeling good.
Now here's how the game works.
Evan, you will start the round
by pressing start
on this buzzer right here.
You draw a clue
from the top of the pile.
You have to get your partner
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible,
then hand the buzzer off
to the person on your...
-Right.
-Yeah, you can make any physical
gesture, say whatever you want,
except you can't say any word
in the actual clue.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
We're gonna play three rounds.
Let's take our positions.
Conan, you're over there, bud.
-All right.
-Am I here?
-Yeah.
Oh, you're over here?
-I think I'm here.
Evan, you're over there.
-I'm here?
-You're over on this side.
-Okay.
-All right, yeah.
-Uh-huh.
-All right.
All right, Evan, I'm gonna
give this to you, bud.
Whenever you're ready, you press
start, draw your clue.
You feel like you have
a connection with Tariq?
-Yes. We're locked in.
-We got this.
-We're pards.
We're pards.
Right there.
Come on.
Double fist.
-Yeah.
-Double fist bump.
All right,
whenever you're ready.
Press start,
and then draw the clue.
[ Intermittent beeping ]
-Okay.
Um, um, um, uh...
"Ghostbusters."
It's a pastry
with filling inside.
It's, like, yellow.
-Pop-Tart.
-No, it's yellow and round
and kind of -- you know --
-[ Stammering ]
-"Ghostbusters."
-Hostess.
-Oh, Twinkies!
-Yes!
-All right, okay.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, Fourth of July!
Pwkk!
-Fireworks.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, a team has an animal
who represents them
and they're called the --
-A team -- a mascot.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, "Star Wars."
-Lightsaber.
-Use the Force.
-Darth Vader.
-Another one.
-"Star Trek."
-No, no, no.
Oh, God, he has --
-Luke Skywalker.
-No, no, no.
-Yoda.
One more, one more.
-Baby Yoda!
Chewbacca!
Han Solo!
-Three words, three words!
Obi-Wan Kenobi!
-That's it!
-Oh!
-Oh, my God.
[ Buzzer ]
-Wow!
-First of all...
[ Laughter ]
First of all...
-All right.
That doesn't count.
-He blocked him!
-I read eight characters
from "Star Wars."
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know what --
Princess Leia is
the only person I didn't say.
Oh, my goodness!
That was fantastic.
-Absolutely counts.
-It absolutely counts.
All right, we're -- hoo!
That was --
I'm sweating, I'm sweating.
Okay. Here we go.
-Wow.
-All right. Here we go.
So it's one.
That's good.
We're gonna play three rounds.
Okay, you can start off again.
Clue number 6.
Here we go.
-All right.
[ Beeping ]
Oh!
You throw it and somebody --
-Frisbee.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
All right. Okay.
Okay.
It's not a strawberry daiquiri,
it's a coconut --
it's a frozen drink.
-Oh, my God, I don't even drink.
-I know.
-Coconut?
-That song --
♪ If you like -- ♪
-Piña coladas!
-Wow!
-Thank you, thank you!
-It's a game you play where you
go around in a circle.
It's bird names.
This bird, this bird,
and then a different bird.
It's like, you go -- people --
you walk around in a circle.
Uh, okay, um...
-Duck, Duck, Goose!
-Yes!
-Oh, my God!
-This bird.
-Oh, my God.
It's a -- oh, my God.
It's made out of --
It's like lobster,
and it's made into, like,
a weird mountain thing,
and you eat it,
and you eat it in Maine,
and it's like lobster-esque,
shrimp-esque.
-Crab?
-Yeah, yeah!
-Imitation crab?
-But it's put into, like,
a weird -- kind of like a cup.
A cup?
-Crab cup? Crab...roll?
[ Buzzer ]
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy!
-It's like a cup?
It's a crabcake.
-But it's not like a cup at all!
How's it like a cup?!
-A cupcake.
A crab cupcake.
-Oh, I see where
you were going with that.
-I thought --
-A roll, a cup.
-I thought you said
a crab in a cup.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Crabcake, yes, of course.
You don't drink,
I don't eat crabcakes.
[ Laughter ]
-But he knows
the piña colada song.
-I know, this is good, yeah.
All right,
let's play one more round.
Guys, this one is worth
1,000 points.
-Oh, wow.
-It's anyone's game, okay?
Conan, it starts with you,
all right?
Let's go, bud.
We got this for the win, yeah.
[ Intermittent beeping ]
-Oh, it's a dinosaur,
and it has little arms.
-T. rex.
-Yeah.
-Nice.
Okay.
Oh, it's another word
for a robot.
Like, a killer robot.
-A cyborg.
-Yes!
-What?!
Cyborg?!
-Geez.
-Okay, "Smartless" is one.
-Phone.
-You listen to a show
on your phone.
-Streaming, Netflix.
-It's not radio.
It's an interview thing.
Could be a true-crime.
-Oh, oh, podcast.
-Yes!
-Nice.
-Um, it's a character
from "Toy Story," the main guy.
-Buzz Lightyear, Woody --
-Right.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, you use it to take the --
the crap out of a toilet.
-Plunger!
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Plunger.
-Oh, God.
Oh, you, you --
-Oh, oh, slide --
Slip 'N Slide.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Headphones but...
-AirPods.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Um --
[ Buzzer ]
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank God!
-You did so good.
You crushed it.
-Oh, I just felt
your heart beating.
That was unbelievable.
-You're a fierce competitor.
-Dude, Slip 'N Slide?
That was the best.
Zhuh! Zhuh! Zhuh!
My thanks to Evan Rachel Wood,
Conan Gray, Tariq Trotter.